- It is time for Drew's News,
(audience cheers loudly)
your daily grating of the
fresh news parmigiano.
And with me at the desk
is my best co-pilot ever,
Ross Matthews.
- Yes, hi.
Parmigiano.
- Parmigiano.
First up in the news,
we're all guilty of a little
impulse purchase now and then,
and The Cut reports
that Nicholas Cage just
revealed one of his.
It's a two-headed snake, and
he bought it for $80,000.
He said he had a dream
about a two-headed eagle,
and then the next day he heard
that the two-headed snake was for sale,
and he was like, obviously.
So unfortunately, it turns out
the two heads did not get along.
He tried putting a spatula
in between them at feedings,
but he said it just got too freaky.
And if it's too freaky for Nicholas Cage,
it's gotta be freaky.
(audience laughs)
- But he safely returned them to a zoo.
You know, when we tell kids
they went to that farm.
- Yeah, yeah, living at.
(audience laughs)
- Well that's where these snakes went.
Ross, thoughts.
- I mean, oh,
this is something only
Nicholas Cage would do,
right, a two-headed snake.
But the freakiest part of the story is
that the heads didn't get along.
I know.
- Right?
Can you imagine you're a two-headed snake,
for starters, you're like, man,
and then the worst part is
you don't like each other.
What? Are you coming over here to be my?
(Drew laughs)
Come here, where are you coming?
- I'll be a two-headed snake with you.
(audience cheers loudly)
Did you ever have your
phone buzz only to look down
and read a text that says,
"Can we talk?"
- Oh my God.
- Refinery 29 reports that experts say
you should never text that to anyone.
If you text, "We need to talk,"
it immediately makes people think
about the absolute worst case scenarios.
It's a heart attack in a text message
and should never be done.
Rossy, thoughts.
- Don't you dare text me this.
Just come on, because
you know what I've done
in that 18 seconds between,
hey we need to talk
and the bubble is that
I've decided everyone died,
right, everyone's gone, they're just dead.
There's a bomb on the
way, hey, you know, boom.
So every single worst case scenario.
They canceled Bridgerton.
What? No! What?
Something terrible is coming.
Just give it to me straight.
- For anyone who loved
The Flight Attendant,
did anyone love The Flight Attendant?
- Gotta love the,
- I'm a fan of that.
- So good.
- Love her, and I love Kaley.
- Well, it's back on HBOMax
and Kaley Cuoco is back
for more nail-biting drama.
But when it comes to marriage,
this flight attendant is cooling her jets.
People reports Kaley just
divorced from Karl Cook,
her second husband, and she says, quote,
"I will never get married again."
She said she'd love a long-term partner,
but marriage is absolutely not happening.
And she said that People could quote her
and put that right on the cover.
- Yeah, yes, and good for
her if that's what she wants.
I don't like it, and I'll tell you why.
Have you ever been in a position
where you ate like a
whole pizza to yourself,
and you're like, oh my God,
I'm never eating pizza again.
And then, you know, a day comes around
when you're like you know what
sounds good is some pizza.
And I'm just telling you,
you may be saying now, Drew,
I never wanna get married again,
but what about one day, 30 years from now,
you meet somebody who's your person
and it's important to them, right?
Do you think maybe then
you change your mind?
- Nope.
- No.
- No, absolutely not.
- What if they fed you pizza?
If we brought it back
around to that, would you?
- If you wrapped anything up in pizza,
I feel like I'd be in.
CNN reports that music
icon Dolly Parton says
that there's only one person
that she would want to
play her in a movie,
and it's none other
than Tony Award-winning,
Broadway powerhouse Kristin Chenoweth.
(audience cheers and applauds)
This makes so much sense.
She says Kristen is absolutely fantastic,
and if there's ever a biopic,
she would be her first choice.
I mean, Rossy.
- It's a no brainer, but I can
(audience laughs)
I do wanna say.
- Rossy, why am I going Parliament,
and you're going Dolly Parton?
I look like I'm a judge in a British show.
Give me a gavel.
What is going on?
- I don't know, but I am
feeling myself in this Dolly.
I tumbled out of bed,
stumble to the kitchen.
Look at me, watch out.
- Pour myself a
- [Drew And Ross] Cup of ambition.
- Watch out Kristin Chenoweth,
I'm coming for your gig.
- And I am going to change legislation.
(upbeat music)